hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan cyber we
could be checking out to recently
release the games of games of war the
games of all the Gears of War for world
premiere gameplay demo released at the
e3 2015 Microsoft conference so let's
check this out it's quite a long video
let's do this
interesting 10 years ago
Gears of War 2 viewed here at the xbox
III briefing and this year we're taking
you back to where it all began today I'm
happy to announce Gears of War Ultimate
Edition the original gears of war
completely remastered and modernized for
Xbox one and coming August 25th it's the
first at its best fully rebuilt in 1080p
loaded with new content and 60 frames
per second and multiplayer frames for
second man and you can play that much
money where mercy and a one week paid
public beta that starts today so tune in
to the Xbox daily live for e3 this
afternoon to learn more oh yeah and one
more thing I want to give you a taste of
something else we're working out of the
coalition Thank You Xbox one exclusive
world premiere
[Music]
got scary
[Music]
certainly like everything every trailer
they do to be dark I can't see [ __ ]
really
Oh separate hello person I don't know
looks like you went this way come on
it's like a song
no one's picking up no need to worry
just yet and watch it that thing could
be it
there's a bull new my very polluted
[Music]
you kind of creeped out now I think I
mean taking a manager right now like
sexually
I guess the mood I guess here's water
here
yeah sure that's safe just remark yeah
that's even a stood [ __ ] it's just him
I'll live
this is that guy's first time playing
this game you don't know that tell me
you've heard that after it what what do
you see I don't know we're about four oh
we can't really see what they're seeing
[Music]
Wow
right
here coming
rather really happen up in my social
game
[Music]
[Music]
now we find out if that thing's dude I'm
gonna have to be very close when I play
this gig hey chief you like an engine
light
she said don't touch it's a little touch
it
Oh Jeannie I'm okay son get short on my
flashlight great stupid let's just get
that right here everything so dark
Oh No
all right party
don't touch the pause
beginning to think we're not the hunters
anymore let's just clear this courtyard
excellent you're the dog freeze Eli
Oh what the hell is that
[Music]
okay you're a big fella there we go
Charcot they know things on that [ __ ]
[Music]
god it's so creepy
just called here's more I guess
all in 8960 alright holiday the one
[ __ ] holiday Christmas usually it just
says holiday
yeah it's there's holidays all year
round oh well it's holiday season is
traditionally Christmas when do people
buy games Christmas when do people get
console Christmas hmm
except for you use people you have
Christmas in July that's in your getting
your Xbox one is my girlfriend finally
do something with me Christmas once here
on the eve of creature very courts there
thanks yeah what I really got from that
was how dark everything what it's like
it's scary to play because when there is
light this [ __ ] they show light upon
tends to be freaky you even if it's in a
flash of thunder like this feels like a
[ __ ] horror movie it definitely feels
a lot more tension in this one what's
really confusing for me is like at the
end of spoilers at the ends of gears
Gears of War 3
basically you cleanse the planet of
everything bad and now all the bad shits
back so I'm really wondering what the
hell happened hmm
for me personally which means I should
probably just buy the game what some
games of gears are worth are you
supposed to be like the trilogy
conclusion yes
it was is that whether you think they're
calling it gears for instead brah I mean
it's the same thing with like Halo 4
like they finished halo 1 through 3 and
then it was like that was one trilogy
and here's like the next stage right and
it's the same thing you did with mass
spec where they type 8 that the plot in
a bow at the end of 3 but they're still
doing more this is like a new main
character who isn't the size of a tank
oddly enough usually those guys are like
twice as thick and have like tree trunk
legs he looks like a friendly like a--
yes a friendly white guy i which i would
share a handshake with teamed up with a
sexy [ __ ] mm-hmm with a BB i want to
see more the designs are good monster
designs the monsters are pretty cool
anytime I see a monster creation where
it has like a mouth that goes walk up
you to like that breaks me out to make
WOD lip yeah I have like multiple
tongues
I was disgusting I'll have multiple
times picking money for a finger cheerio
I mean it looks good I just want to know
more before I decide to buy it or not
that's kind of where I'm at I understand
your concerns Dan it's not a concern I
understand your feelings that's good if
you're used to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out Dan's gaming channel that
cyber channel does a lot of Let's Plays
on whatnots
hmm you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter and vine because if we
get enough followers we can get product
placement for things such as Sierra Mist
Sierra Mist is great it is delicious
caffeine free and it is known to
actually help you produce more sperm
so when ya come on a little later not a
little one that's illegal
if you come on a lady of adult age you
know you just you ever more sperm you
know you just gave Sierra Mist the plug
that they now don't have to pay you for
Sierra Mist